I'm a gentleman now I don't know if you
guys know I'm an older gentleman so I
drink whiskey and of course because I'm
an [ __ ] I drink the most expensive
and I've discovered a new whiskey called
Blanton's I think plans I think whiskey
not only does it not do me any favors I
think it exacerbates my psoriasis as
well as sugar it does whiskey yeah yeah
so it [ __ ] me up yeah yeah so no more
whiskey for Brian you need a drink
though as an older gentleman see mines
Campari still I like that
I like an expensive bourbon I'll be
honest I like a smooth expensive bourbon
just not there yet you got a bday coming
up I got a bday 5151 that hurts me 51
I was just difficulty oh I know what's
tonight well I mean last year yeah I
know but it doesn't seem like a year no
time is going fast for us buddy it
really is what should we do on your beat
ob6 much um I think we should go to
Prada and buy me a couple of boots bra
yeah I said it and then uh what do I
need
I got an iPad pro oh it's an iPad um I
don't know how to use technical - dinner
dinner
I like dinner I like laughing I like
eating well I'll drink too much wine and
feel like [ __ ] the next day some free my
face super swollen for the next day
that's what we'll do at 51 we'll get my
face super Swan I'll tell you something
else about 50 I don't know if this
happens use you're an athlete when I
wake up like I did slept nine hours when
I wake up a solid set of sleep oh yeah
because the night before I slept for so
slept nine and then I got up and I tried
to walk and I couldn't my feet need to
warm up and need to warm the oh they
won't work they sure won't they get
super stiff so I've got a warm feet up
so yeah that in bed and they come out
I'm wigging out yeah I gotta wiggle them
out I don't know yeah I stand up in my
hand my Achilles heel is like what
excuse me
we are old meat sir and then I gotta
move my even my feet don't bend what
yeah
so you so if a Robert Gamez can take you
a little bit us what exactly what I
thought
I thought somebody's attacking my kids
right now um you gotta warm up l
wouldn't feet l wouldn't you know I've
got a wit
yeah I got wood for feet I got clogs on
you gotta wait till I
so I break the wood in I don't how many
problems yeah like that how does that
happen
[ __ ] I don't know amen maybe we should
get on HD eight now you're talking and
really exacerbates something else you
didn't live I'm gonna do that now
because I'm afraid of that it
accelerates cell division so if you have
to so everything yeah here we go I'll do
testosterone though and not HGH now test
test I'll do test eventually when I feel
like my dick when my dick stops being
able to carve a diamond when my [ __ ]
stops being able to cut glass it's not
clothes cuz I got a dick on me and I'm
my dick is ten-hut he reaches for the
sky at 50 I'll [ __ ] all day I'll out
[ __ ] everybody cuz I'm a dirtbag yeah I
know and my dick when my dick is when I
feel like my dick when I got a lazy
boner when he starts getting lazy go
soft in the middle then I'm Bennett's
coat IV it's weekend yeah right now I
got energy for everything is good at
home thanks for asking I have a five
week old little Priya Priya Leila named
Beverly Lally love it uh Priya Leila she
sleeps all day and parties all night so
I'm trying to fill that schedule welcome
to club a little tired I know I tried to
come in here with high energy I was
pumped that I got to see you and you
give me good energy try cuz you're one
of those guys I've been up since 5:00
with the little man myself do you know
about this Bryan Callen mem a going
around that he died in a car wreck no no
I just did a live show inspired by you
and Joe Rogan inspired by your fight to
pay so Ryan Parsons comes out we set up
the camera we go online we're doing a
live show and it comes with a question
from the audience can ask and interact
and ask question we're watching the
fight we're doing to fight campaign yeah
ripping off you guys's idea answer some
questions right well it comes up
somebody says uh I will miss Bryan
Callen like yeah I miss him too of a
back to the fight you know it says now
he just died in a car wreck and right I
mean we're live when we stop everything
and go hey what do you tom and when
we're talking the audience good if this
is a joke it's not funny so stop you
know what what is going on in I call
Bryan instantly goes straight to
voicemail
well apparently there's something that's
been going around for like 15 years
Bryan Callen mem a what Emmy Emmy am I
saying that right may
Oh a meme okay Bryan Callen meme and
something about him in a car wreck it's
not funny
I thought I'm gonna bring it up to you
it's not now he's not dead I just saw me
and I don't know I don't know where that
came from or why they insert but as soon
as Ryan and I got real and it was very
real and authentic that's scary man the
listeners were cool enough to quickly go
whoa whoa wait a minute no no no we
thought we thought you knew about this
we thought you knew about this for your
birthday what do you want to do me you
want me to get your BDD SD QRS or no
with Italians with a baby face
no I can't do that I'm just going to
dinner
yeah well go to dinner I told you I use
I use that massage app company and they
sent over just this just I mean you
wanna test my patience they sent over a
result it did did the dimepiece
chocolate dream sheet even lie dormant
okay man that's a problem came at you
went where are we gonna set up I went
bring that extra bedroom how about on
this dick yeah yeah chocolate dream just
not like this a nightmare keep your
mouth shut
do you electric cash give you a little
extra cash
we'll let you cash yeah I'm talking like
a ten came to my door was like alright
what's going on here
we should perfect super professional I'm
the best massage that I've ever had wow
that was nice man oh man tough not to
have an interaction I'm gonna give you
balls a little tug here if you don't
mind you know when they get that yeah
you know shank shank yeah I thought it
was I thought they were trying to test
me I thought maybe Joe set it up you
know yeah right but then I talked in
code to see you know I went uh dog like
an Italian she goes I don't know what
that is all right we're good you're
legit how about a BBD how do you have a
baby face of DD judge to completion she
said no she went I have no idea what
you're talking about all right this is
legit god that [ __ ] all like timeless
houses I bet you they have to deal with
that all my gosh oh my god little that
sure like I would never [ __ ] I'd
first I don't want to make her feel
weird also I don't want to be that
[ __ ] creep even though I am you will
mate when your massage they go go ahead
and change and what you're comfortable I
don't go butt-naked
I usually my shorts on my undies
the guys who go butt-naked that's always
suspect dude people are so paranoid on
set now like I was just on set and this
really sweet guy he's a veteran and he's
our he does he does he's crew he's part
of the crew and he's such a nice guy and
he said you know he's been he was in the
military a long times I'm so lucky I get
free breakfast I get to work with these
bro
because I get to work with these pretty
and he pointed to one of the makeup
women beautiful one of these pretty any
goes sorry sorry I didn't mean it and
she goes you called me pretty
and I said yeah and I am too it's fine
you know but he was so scared she this
is what we're at always paranoid nothing
dude it's all good